for over 200 years the world has been
set on fire by a revolutionary message
the message is that every individual
human being is a divine that all of us
despite the constraints and humiliations
that surround us can share in a greater
life and share even in the attributes
that we ascribe to God
nevertheless the ordinary experience of
human beings remains an experience of
belittlement this revolutionary message
can only be made real through a series
of transformations transformations in
how we organize society in how we live
and in how we understand the world it is
not enough to innovate in our politics
we must also innovate in our basic ideas
about who we are unless we innovate in
these ideas as well as in the
arrangements of society we cannot turn
the message of our divinity into a real
experience and thus the need today for a
spiritual revolution as well as for a
social transformation the focus of my
thinking expressed in this book the
religion of the future lies precisely
there in the relation between the
transformation of personal experience
and the reorganization of social life
all the major religions and philosophies
that have exerted the greatest influence
over the last two thousand years arose
from a series of religious revolutions
that took place around 2,000 years ago
and these religions took three main
directions one direction one might call
overcoming the world and an example is
Buddhism and the philosophies that
prevailed in ancient India but it is a
position also represented in modern
Western thought for example by
Schopenhauer according to this view all
the distinctions and changes that
surround us are illusory our task if we
are to escape from suffering is to
communicate with the hidden and unified
being and to escape this nightmare of
the apparent world a second orientation
one might call the humanization of the
world and its teaches us that in a
meaningless world we can create meaning
we can open a clearing space a social
order that bears the imprint of our
humanity and in particular we can do so
by creating a society that conforms to a
model of what we owe to one another by
virtue of occupying certain roles the
most important example of this position
in the history of religion and the
philosophy has been Confucianism the
third direction is the direction that I
call in this book the religion of the
future the struggle with the world it
tells us that there is a trajectory of
ascent by which through changes in how
we live and in how we organize society
we can rise to a greater life and share
in the attributes that we ascribe to God
and thus this ascent requires a struggle
and so I call it the struggle with the
world
now this third Direction has had two
main phases in history a sacred face and
a profane face the sacred face is
represented in the Semitic monotheism's
Judaism Christianity and Islam and the
profane face in the political projects
of liberalism socialism and democracy
and in the project of personal
liberation that has been represented by
romanticism both the original Romantic
movement and the worldwide popular
romantic culture the third direction
teaches us that each of us is bigger
than he seems to be that each of us is
called to share in the greater life and
to participate in this divinity that we
sometimes treat as a separate entity
they created the world and that
intervenes in history it is this third
direction that has exerted the greatest
influence on humanity over the last
couple of centuries in forming a series
of revolutionary projects in politics
and in culture that have set the whole
world on fire but all of these religions
in each of these three directions that I
have just described
despite their immense differences share
certain common characteristics one of
these characteristics is that they have
represented as it were a kind of
two-sided ticket one side of the ticket
is a license to escape the world a
second side of the ticket is an
invitation to change the world and this
ambivalence has never been fully
resolved another common characteristic
of these religions is that each of them
in some way denies or seeks to
compensate for the incorrigible flaw
was in the human condition our mortality
our groundlessness and our insatiability
despite the fecundity of our experience
despite this fundamental aspect of our
humanity which is that there is always
more in us than there is in all of the
social and conceptual worlds that we
build and inhabit we are all doomed to
die we cannot look into the beginning
and end of time or understand the
framework of our existence our
presuppositions never reach rock bottom
the bottom is bottomless thus our
groundlessness and all of us human
beings demand the unlimited from the
limited and project this demand for the
unlimited on two particular
inappropriate objects thus our
insatiability all of these religions
have attempted to say that there is a
solution and antidote that we in fact
will not die or at least that there is
some compensation some compensation for
these enigmas and terrors of our
existence an entirely different moment
in the history of religion would begin
if we accepted these realities for what
they are and no longer attempted to deny
them given the enormous impact of the
third direction that I described the
struggle with the world on humanity over
the last two centuries when my desk what
is the core of its message and why has
this message been so seductive there are
two ideas that that stand at the center
of this
view of the world both on its religious
side the Near Eastern religions of
salvation Judaism Christianity and Islam
and on its profane side the projects of
political and personal liberation one
set of ideas has to do with the relation
between the self and others the dominant
view in the history of world religion
and philosophy and indeed in modern
academic moral philosophy is that the
fundamental problem of moral life is
selfishness and the solution to
selfishness is a principle of altruism
and this principle of altruism is to be
enforced by conformity to certain rules
that define our obligations to one
another and these rules are to be
determined by some conceptual method
like Khan's categorical imperative or
Bentham's calculus of the greatest
happiness for the greatest number there
is an attitude connected to those ideas
the attitude is that we should try to
come to the end of our lives blameless
with clean hands
having discharged our obligations to one
another on the green side of our book of
moral accounts but that is not the view
that stands at the core of the moral
beliefs of this third tradition there
the view is that the basic problem of
our moral experience is not selfishness
but rather a contradiction in the
conditions of personality and in our
relations to other people we need the
others we make ourselves into human
beings only through connection but every
connection is a threat every connection
jeopardizes our free
autonomy are self-construction
and thus all of our relations to the
others are shadowed by an inescapable
ambivalence Sartre says the others are
held describing aphoristic Lee this one
side of this ambivalence so what is then
the solution that that that lies at the
center of this idea the solution is
radical love in the circle of intimacy
and then some form of cooperation a free
and equal cooperation outside the circle
of intimacy but this practical solution
if one can call it that depends on an
imaginative capability the capacity to
imagine the others to imagine their
other nests and that is then the the
teaching the real teaching that lies at
the at the center of this tradition for
the ancients and for most of the world
religions and philosophies the highest
ideal was the ideal of an impersonal and
impersonal and detached benevolence from
from on high from a distance implying no
no risk on the part of of the out rest
of the benevolent person but here now
comes a different conception that this
impersonal altruism this gift of
benevolence from on high is in fact not
the center of our moral experience that
the highest form of moral experience is
reconciliation with the other on the
basis of equality and at the price of a
heightened vulnerability now there's a
second set of ideas at the center of
this tradition and the second set of
ideas has to do with the relation
between the structures of social life
and the human spirit now what I mean by
spirit is the aspect of our humanity
that has to do with our excess over all
the regimes that we create and inhabit
now there are two distortions that have
had a long career in the history of
religious and philosophical thinking one
distortion might be called The Hague
alien heresy it's the idea that there is
a definitive structure towards which
history is evolving and which will be
the final home of the human spirit and
the other heresy one might call the
Sartre in heresy or the romantic air at
sea or the existentialist heresy and it
was prefigured by the mystics within
Judaism Christianity and Islam according
to this heresy every structure is death
to the spirit so the routines of
marriage by contrast to romantic love or
the bureaucratic apparatus of the state
in opposition to the crowd in the
streets we can't get rid of the
structures definitively but we can
momentarily rebel against them and these
interludes of rebellion are then the
time when we become most fully human so
it is a kind of despair it is a failure
of our hope of changing the relation of
structure to spirit now these two sets
of ideas about the self and others and
spirit and structure have never been
adequately developed much less fully
realized in political and personal
practice in the history of our
civilizations both the political
doctrines and the religious traditions
have lived
in compromise with the existing forms of
social organization and with ethical
attitudes that contradict their impulse
that is another reason for spiritual
revolution now if we were to take these
ideas seriously if we were to push them
to the hilt if we were to ask how we
should live under the light of these
ideas we would come to a completely
different conception a completely
different conception of our situation in
the world and of the way to organize
society we have in fact in the history
of our culture in the history of the
culture that has been shaped by this
third tradition the tradition of the
struggle with the world only two
completely developed images of how to
live one is the image of the sacrificial
altruist who devotes himself to the
others without experiencing any intimate
risk or jeopardy and the other is the
image of the romantic adventurer who
experienced life as a perpetual trial in
the effort to deepen and affirm his
subjectivity neither of these images is
adequate as a conception of how to live
and the the absence of an alternative
view demonstrates once again the need
for religious revolution now one should
begin by understanding the the points of
departure the the provocations for for
such a such a spiritual change
so one provocation is the need no longer
to deny the incurable
defects in the human condition our
mortality our groundlessness and our
insatiability a second provocation is
the importance of not confusing our
belittlement with these inescapable
defects in human life we are belittled
and humiliated all of us in some way to
some degree but this belittlement has a
cure unlike our mortality our
groundlessness and our insatiability the
cure is for us to make ourselves bigger
to ascend to a higher life and that cure
requires a reorientation of the way we
live and of the way in which we work in
our society and a third provocation to
this spiritual change is then the the
the unwillingness to allow those ideas
about self and others and spirit and
structure to be compromised and
circumvented as they have been in the
history of our religions and of our
societies so what does this mean what
does this mean by way of a moral
orientation and what does it mean by way
of a political project let me illustrate
what it means by way of a moral
orientation by referring to how each of
us is to respond to one of the
characteristic incidents in every human
life as we grow older each of us a cell
of compromise and routine begins to form
around us
the self becomes rigidify din a
character the ancient Greek said that
characters fate character is the
rigidify form of the self and the
marriage of the character with a social
circumstance to which we are resigned
then becomes a proxy for the living self
that begins to form around each of us
within which each of us slowly dies many
small deaths what we must then do is to
break the mummy apart the better to live
and to become more godlike so that we
can live we do not live to become more
godlike we become more godlike to live
and how are we to break the mummy apart
we cannot simply will ourselves
transformed but the will can project us
into situations in which we are
unprotected in which we lose our
habitual protections in which we are
forced to become more vulnerable and in
this way awaken to to a greater life so
the rebellion against mummification is
one of the many telling consequences of
such a reorientation to existence and
what does it mean by way of a political
project for two centuries now
ideological debate in the world has
taken the form of a contrast between
what you might call shallow equality and
shallow freedom the major political
forces in the world except the
established institutions
and then we think that the Conservatives
are those who within that institutional
framework give priority to freedom and
the progressives were leftists or those
who give priority to a quality but it is
shallow equality against shallow freedom
because it's based on this acceptance of
the established framework now suppose we
imagine that we can begin to change this
framework to innovate in the
institutions that define the market
economy and democratic politics to
democratize the market economy and to
deepen democracy the method is the
cumulative institutional transformation
of society and what is the objective the
objective is not equality of outcome or
circumstance the objective is a greater
life for the ordinary man or woman
that's I would say deep freedom who then
are the progressives or revolutionaries
today first they are those who refuse to
take the established institutional
structure for granted and second they
are those who demand not simply to
sugarcoat those structures with some
compensatory redistribution but to bring
the mass of ordinary men and women to a
greater level of intensity of capability
and of scope so that they can live eyes
wide awake and share in these attributes
in these attributes of transcendence
that we ascribe to the divine and that
then projects us into a world of
institutional proposals and
institutional changes
you